how many of these accidents included
drunk driving we don't know how many
included reckless driving we don't know
how many included pedestrians walking
out into traffic
we don't know we don't know any of those
things the only thing that we know
is more black people than white people
on a percentage level are being killed
therefore racism
therefore roads and the deeper point
here is that when you attribute
everything
in the world to meismatic forces of
racism it makes it very very difficult
to solve problems which of course is the
whole
point when you make problems difficult
to solve and then you implicate the
entire system
the notion is that you're going to have
to tear down the entire system in order
to solve the problems
everything has to be nuked you have to
just tear down everything and then
finally
once we've salted the earth and and burn
the remains of the old system
then we can build the new except that
that doesn't actually solve problems
that makes things a lot worse
in the near term so perfect example
today in the washington post
there's an article in the washington
post is at the top of their website
today titled traffic deaths increased
during the pandemic the toll fell more
heavily on black residents
report shows a new analysis found that
even before 2020's increased black
people were killed on roads
on roads at a rate almost 25 percent
higher than white people
now let's just say that you you read
that stat
right that that for a very long time
black deaths on roads outpaced
white deaths on roads your first
thought might be who's speeding right i
mean that that might be your first
thought
that would be a natural thought in the
same way that if you read
a statistic that said that black people
are being murdered at a rate
far higher than white people and we know
that the vast majority of murder is
intra-racial it is black on black or
white on white
but black people are being murdered at a
way higher rate you might think to
yourself
well that's probably the reason is that
a lot of black people are murdering a
lot of black people
so if you see a stat in which it says
that a lot of black people are dying in
traffic accidents you might think to
yourself
what is the behavior of the drivers
right because you would think that
that's literally your first question
forget about groups with regard to
individuals right if you hear that
anybody
has died of anything your first question
is what were the circumstances
surrounding their death
this is true for anybody's death if
somebody you know dies in a car accident
your first question is how
right you don't ask questions typically
about the roads you don't ask questions
typically about the lights typically you
ask okay where are they speeding and if
somebody says oh they were speeding you
go oh okay well you know that's terrible
but you know
you're speeding right like you should
probably pay attention to the traffic
signs
this entire washington post piece is
designed specifically
to ignore the question of who is doing
the speeding right because if it turns
out that black drivers are speeding more
often than white drivers
that at least partially explains the
discrepancy between black
and white death statistics with regard
to traffic accidents instead the entire
new york times the entire washington
post article rather is dead
is dedicated to the proposition that
it's institutional racism
that causes higher levels of black
deaths so here's what the washington
post
and and again what this means is that
solutions become a lot more difficult
because let's say for example that the
problem really is disproportionate
speeding inside the black community and
the reason i say that is because we have
fairly good evidence from the past
that there is in fact this proportion of
speeding inside the black community so
to take an example
in the early 1990s there was a big hub
up during the clinton administration
about supposed racial profiling on the
new jersey turnpike
there's a lot of focus on this look at
these terrible cops they're pulling over
black drivers even though it was at
night it's kind of hard to see the color
of the person who's driving but they're
pulling over
black drivers at a rate higher than
white drivers that must be the latent
racism
of the new of the new jersey states and
they're just pulling black people over
then finally there was a study and the
study
was put out only about almost a decade
later
and what the study found is that a very
high percentage of the speeders
were black right it turns out that black
drivers were just driving faster as a
general rule than white drivers were
according to this particular study right
it was it was an actual justice
department study
in conjunction with the state offices of
new jersey
and what they found was leaked to the
new york times what they found is that
while black drivers were making about 16
of the drivers on the new jersey
turnpike 25 of the speeders in the 65
mile per hour zone where
profiling complaints were the most
common were black
right black drivers sped about twice as
much as white drivers and sped at
reckless levels even more
in fact according to that particular
justice department study blacks were
actually stopped less than their
speeding behavior would predict
they're about 23 of those stopped okay
so
all of this is to not make any linkage
between genetic
skin color and how fast you drive but if
the question is
which groups of people are driving the
fastest in american life and how does
that link to traffic stops you might
think that that might be like a
consideration in the washington post
piece
no they weren't even going to consider
it in fact
and especially they weren't going to
consider it because if that were in fact
the problem if the problem were
a disproportionate number of people are
speeding in a particular area therefore
a higher number of people are dying
in that particular area more people are
driving recklessly in this particular
area therefore more people are dying
the answer to that right the very easy
policy answer to that is
okay so you set up a speed trap right
you get a bunch of cops
you put them in the area and you have
them sign a lot of traffic tickets
because you create an incentive
structure where it makes no sense to
speed
right that is the that is the perfect
obvious policy solution
the washington post does not want that
policy solution so they go out of their
way to find alternative explanations
that are far less less explained they
literally do not even
posit the possibility that people are
speeding at higher rates
on a correlative level with regard to
race even though
they're saying that you can measure
traffic deaths as
on the basis of race we can't measure
traffic behavior on the basis of race
which seems like you're ignoring kind of
a rather large factor are you not
it's sort of like the the move that that
people in the media are constantly
making where they look at big tech and
they're like well
they're just not enough engineers who
are in big tech who are black
you're like right but how many qualified
applicants are coming from the black
community
who are qualified engineers to be in big
tech and they just ignore that they
won't even put that in the story
even though that is the vast majority of
the explanation right it's not the big
tech
is going around like well i have an
equally qualified black person and white
person i'm picking the white person no
one in big tech is doing that they're
doing precisely the opposite
okay so here's how the washington post
tries to explain this discrepancy
a new analysis of deaths on us rhodes
found that black people were killed in
traffic
crashes at a rate almost 25 than white
people in recent years
a disparity that appears to have
worsened it during the corona virus
pandemic
last year was especially grim on the
roads the number of miles driven
decreased as many people stayed home
yet traffic deaths rose seven percent
according to the national highway
traffic safety administration in large
part because of people driving faster on
empty highways
okay so right off the bat they're
acknowledging that when people drive
faster
you end up with more people dead right
so they're not this is true across the
broad population
but we cannot even measure the traffic
behavior differential between groups
when trying to explain the traffic death
differential between groups
because to do so would imply a solution
they don't want
and we're also implied that racism isn't
the problem so you don't have to tear
down the entire system
the number of black people killed
according to the washington post climbed
the reason for the spike in black dots
is not noted in the federal report
but experts say ah the experts
experts say just as the virus itself
spread more readily through communities
of color
the increase was probably a result of
existing inequities being compounded
or possibly it was a result of
the the differential in behavior being
compounded
because if you have more people who are
speeding on the roads during this time
generally you're going to end up with
more people who speed as a percentage of
that
being killed researchers have previously
concluded that black communities tend to
be crisscrossed by more dangerous roads
during the pandemic people of color were
more likely to be employed in essential
jobs without the option to stay home
people were driving faster amid lower
traffic levels meant crashes were more
likely to be deadly
okay so the the basic premise here is
that the roads are racist right the
roads because they're in poor
communities
and because these are bigger roads with
fewer trees and people tend to speed
more on those roads
that this is the real rationale so
presumably we should have traffic
bottlenecks
in these areas which i'm not sure how
that would solve many other problems
having to do with the economy having to
do with transport
if you're living in a poorer area with
fewer businesses you need to get to work
you actually don't want fewer lanes on
the roads
but put all that aside the basic notion
that this has to do with race as opposed
to with class
is another confound it turns out the
poorer areas very often are crisscrossed
with more dangerous roads i mean those
poorer areas generally exist around for
example highways because people who are
richer don't want to live
next to highways right people who are
richer don't want to live next to big
roads with lots of traffic which is why
people who are richer tend to move out
to the suburbs for example
the nhtsa estimated that 38 680 people
were killed in crashes nationwide last
year
said 7 494 of them were black a new
study released tuesday by the governor's
highway safety association highlights
the disparities it analyzed data from
2015 to 2019 right so not including the
pandemic
okay and found that in different types
of traffic crashes black people were
killed at rates higher than white people
black pedestrians were killed at a rate
twice as high
and so who is who was driving the cars
would be relevant
and what levels of speed were they
attaining while they were driving the
cars and by the way what was the
behavior of the pedestrians right these
are all relevant factors
to whether people are being killed in
traffic accidents or not and none of
these factors are taken into account in
the washington post
none charles brown professor at rutgers
university school of planning and public
policy
said the figures leave at transportation
officials facing a simple question quote
we've all been socialized in a way to
believe that black death is due to black
behavior
when instead we know infrastructure
influences behavior
if that is true we need investments in
quality infrastructure in black
communities how many more black people
do we have to lose before that is the
number one
priority okay so it can't be that we
focus on
lowering rates of reckless driving
lowering rates of speed
following traffic laws no we have to
restructure
all the roads to what reduce the number
of lanes i mean
to to lower the speed limit that people
are apparently ignoring
the ghsa represents state agencies that
administer federal money to tackle
problems such as drunken and distracted
driving again we don't know the rates of
that
this story does not include any of that
data many of these accidents included
drunk driving we don't know how many
included reckless driving we don't know
how many included pedestrians walking
out into traffic
we don't know we don't know any of those
things the only thing that we know is
more black people than white people on a
percentage level are being killed
therefore racism therefore roads
okay now what's what's kind of amazing
about all of this is that then you look
at some of the statistics that are sort
of buried down in here right first you
get the
typical equity speak from the biden
administration of pete boudijaj
issuing a statement that the
administration is now proposing a 20
billion dollar
yeah we're going to spend 20 billion
bucks on this traffic safety proposal to
reduce crashes and road deaths as part
of its infrastructure plan buddha judge
said last year's traffic fatality rates
and the racial disparities reflected in
them are unacceptable this reflects
broader patterns of inequity in our
country et cetera et cetera et cetera
okay so then you get to the actual
differences among racial and ethnic
groups
now what's fascinating about this is who
is getting killed
in these traffic accidents because it
turns out that it is not solely income
based
right hispanics as well as native
hawaiians and pacific islanders
were killed at rates slightly lower than
whites
weird because on a household income
level hispanics do
pretty significantly worse right now
than white americans do not only that
they tend to live
in lower income areas because of that
presumably
many of the same lower income areas that
are crisscrossed with the same kind of
roads that are being blamed for higher
black fatalities
american indians and alaska natives were
killed at much higher rates
more than twice the rate of black
residents
guillermo narvaez a lecturer at the
university of minnesota who has studied
traffic safety in tribal areas said
american indian communities
are often remote and suffer from unsafe
road designs
so it must be the unsafe road designs
now nowhere in here
is is contemplated the possibility that
there are higher levels of reckless
driving
in american indian reservations for
example or higher levels of dui
example like this is not like these
possibilities are never taken into
account
human behavior is of no consequence
because equal outcome
is the supposed norm except that it's
not the supposed norm again
in any human endeavor you can take
groups of people you take this office
and the office next door
and there will be complete disparities
and differentials between the two
offices
not based on race because equal outcome
among groups is not
human norm it doesn't exist anywhere on
earth at any time in any place
okay but what does this all cover for
i'll tell you that in one second because
it really is
they kind of give away the game late in
this article from the washington post
and the reason that this
is so important is because when you ex
when you
insist that equal outcome must be
the the goal regardless of behavior and
then you
militantly refuse to look at individual
behavior or how behavior
agglomerates in groups you are dictating
unfairness injustice and violation of
individual rights and making life worse
for the people
who actually aren't engaging in the
behavior here's where the washington
post
goes with this okay so they first
try to say that it's about the roads
that because minority communities are
bisected very often
by many lanes long distances between
stop lights few trees this signals that
drivers can go fast
it signals the drivers can go fast and
we're not going to talk about
again racial differentials and speeding
we're going to talk about what the roads
signal
okay this is this is where okay buried
all the way down the bottom of the
article is the actual solution to this
okay
traffic stops okay the the ghsa study
says enforcement of traffic laws is an
effective way to improve safety now
remember
very early on this article the
washington post said the ghsa
offers no opinion as to the cause
of these traffic accidents none okay but
they do offer a
possible solution enforce the traffic
laws
the ghsa study says enforcement of
traffic laws is an effective way to
improve safety but acknowledges the
police stops of black people are under
renewed scrutiny
saying they should be conducted only in
a way that has the support of local
communities
traffic stops sometimes involve police
confronting black drivers to pursue
criminal investigations not related to
road safety
the ghsa analysis also found that black
people were killed in crashes involving
a police pursuit
at a rate four times higher than white
people wait um
excuse me so now the big problem is that
the police are enforcing the traffic
laws
because again no no again it's amazing
it's a consistent rule
never look at the rationale for the
disparity
only blame some sort of meismatic
discrimination
hey again black people were killed in
crashes involving a police pursuit at a
rate four times higher than white people
do we know
who is who is running away from the
police at the highest rates of speed
have we seen each of those individual
circumstances what are the base numbers
there
because really like how many people are
killed in crashes involving a police
pursuit total you may be looking at a
differential of like eight versus two
right it's not like thousands of people
are killed every year in crashes
involving a police pursuit
again refusal to look at individual
behavior is the
is the basic media frame here
it is what they insist upon and what
does this result in
it results in more dead black people
just like with crime
okay when you don't police crime and
with more dead black people you know
police traffic you end up with more dead
black people
and because if it turns out that the
underlying rationale for the disparity
is individual behavior and you won't
police the individual behavior you get
more of the individual behavior
so here's the natural outcome ap
portland oregon today
police in oregon's largest city are
being advised to no longer pursue
low-level traffic infractions including
expired plates and broken headlights
unless related to an immediate safety
threat portland mayor ted wheeler
announced tuesday
in addition if police do stop a driver
they must receive recorded consent
before searching the vehicle and clearly
informing the person they have the right
to refuse
wheeler said both changes are an attempt
to refocus on immediate threats and are
also occurring in response to data
showing a disproportionate impact on
black drivers for traffic stops and
vehicle searchers
searches while six percent of
portlanders are black he said they
account for 18
of traffic stops in the city is this
going to make the city safer
is it the answer of course is no but
when you buy into the lie that equal
outcome is the natural state of things
and that equal behavior is happening
across every group
you are going to pursue bad policy that
results in really really bad results
when you pursue the lie that equal
outcome is the natural state of things
regardless of behavior and when you do
as ibrahim kennedy says and you say
well if there is a differential in
behavior then you're
implying racial inferiority i'm not
implying anything
i'm saying that there are differences in
human behavior across a wide variety
of of human interactions and activities
that's just a fact
hey forget about rationale for a second
that is a simple fact and refusal to
acknowledge simple facts on the ground
means you're going to end up not only in
la la land but in dangerous
la la land like for example undermining
the police and suggesting that the
police are responsible for these
disparities
because if it's not individual behavior
that agglomerates in communities at
different rates
well then it must be the police who are
really the problem
it also leads you to lie so here's mayor
laurie lightfoot in chicago for example
boasting of decline in crime in her city
while the murder rate is up 30
this year the reality is
june over june so from last year to this
one what we've seen is a
downward trend in both homicides and
shootings
and if you look at where we were in
january
to where we are now we're also seeing a
downward trajectory
in both homicides and shootings we're
different
than other cities across the country
every
major city in the united states last
year and this year
has seen an unprecedented rise in
violence we're down on every other major
category
but particularly in shootings um and
homicides
uh related to gun violence okay so i
mean
it's it's amazing she's like well we're
down from last year oh you mean when
there was no cop anywhere to be seen
so your baseline is last year
interesting
i've also noted that like dozens of
people are being shot every weekend in
chicago mayor lori lightfoot
and you've declared racism a public
health problem so murder not a public
health problem in chicago
racism a public health problem in
chicago how's this for a title
ben shapiro show subscriber destroys
like button with clicks and logic
i'd watch that make it happen gang